ALBERT MEYER: The
pigeonhole principle
is accounting principle.
It's so obvious that
you may not have
noticed that you're using it.
In simple form, it
says that if there
are more pigeons than
pigeonholes, then
you have to have at least
two pigeons in the same hole.
OK.
We'll get some mileage
out of that shortly.
But let's remember
that this is actually
just an informal way of saying
something that we've formally
seen already.
One of the mapping
rules is that if you
have a total injection
from a set A to a set B,
that implies that
the size of A is
less than or equal
to the size of B.
And taking the
contrapositive of that,
it means that if the size of A
is greater than the size of B,
then no total injection
from A to B is possible.
No total injection
means that there's
no relation that has an
arrow out of everything in A
and at most one arrow into
B. If everything out of A
has an arrow out
of it, there have
to be at least two arrows,
two pigeons, coming
to the same pigeonhole in B.
So we know this rule already.
And the only thing that's
surprising about it
is how you make use of it.
We're not going to make
elaborate uses of it
in this little video.
You can read in the text about
some amusing applications
about proving that there have to
be 3 people in the Boston area
with more than 10,000
hairs in their heads.
But the exact same
number, or that
there have to be two different
subsets of 90 numbers,
of 25 digits, that
have the same sum.
But we will take a much
more modest application
of the pigeonholing principle.
Namely, if I have
a set of five cards
that I have to have at least two
cards with the same suit, why?
Well, there are four suits--
spades hearts, diamonds,
clubs-- indicated here.
And if you have
five cards, there's
more pigeons cards
than suits holes.
So if you're going to
assign a pigeon to a hole,
again, the pigeons are
going to have to crowd up.
There are going to have
to be at least two pigeons
in the same hole, at least
two cards of the same suit,
maybe more.
OK.
Slight generalizations.
Suppose I have 10 cards.
How many cards must I
have of the same suit?
What number of cards
of the same suit
am I guaranteed to have no
matter what the 10 cards are?
Well, now, if I
have the four slots
and I'm trying to
distribute 10 cards,
is it possible that I had less
than three cards in every hole?
No, because if I have only
two cards in every hole,
then I have at most 8
elements and I got 10
to distribute in the four slots.
I have to bunch them up and
have at least three cards
of the same suit.
You could check that I needn't
have any more of course.
So the reasoning here
is that the number
of cards with the
same suit is going
to be what you get by dividing
up the 10 cards that you
have by the four slots.
And argue that at
least one of the slots
has to have an average number
of cards, namely, 10 over 4.
They can't all be below average.
And of course since there are
an integer number of cards,
you could round up
this-- remember,
these corner braces mean round
up to the nearest integer.
So 10 divided by
4 rounded up is 3,
and that's a lower bound
on the number of cards
that you have to
bunch up in one slot.
More generally, if
I have n pigeons,
and I'm going to be assigning
pigeons to unique holes,
and if I have H
holes, then some hole
has to have n divided
by H rounded up.
Again, n divided by
H can be understood
as the average number
of pigeons per hole.
And the pigeonhole
principle can be
formulated as saying
at least one whole has
to have greater than or
equal to the average number.
And that is the generalized
pigeonhole principle.